Cody what's up what's your background
what's your questions hey Sam good to
see you good to talk to you finally my
background while I was raised Christian
became an atheist for a good portion of
my life since then the Holy Spirit has
rebuked me convicted me and brought me
back to the Faith
Lord I was recently I've only been
studying apologetics and and and defense
of the faith for only about a year now
and I was recently asked a question
about
from someone who's also interested about
Saturday versus Sunday Sabbath all right
so what are they telling
you they just didn't understand why if
if the Sabbath
is Tech according to the to the Old
Testament
in uh the the uh
Saturday why then do we worship on on
Sunday why do we celebrate the Sabbath
on Sunday well
because go ahead no go who are you
saying go ahead I kind of I didn't have
a solid answer to give I kind of came up
with an answer on the Fly which was
that since Jesus Christ Our Lord is Lord
of the Sabbath and through him we have
our Sabbath
rest as long as we are honoring Christ
we are honoring the Sabbath yeah yeah
you got answer if you want to if you
want to celebrate the Sabbath on
Saturday that's fine if you want to do
it on Sunday that's fine Monday that's
fine well
actually if we follow the church that
Jesus established remember First Timothy
3:15 they made it mandatory that we
gather on Sunday because that's the day
where our lord Jesus ushered in our
Everlasting rest he conquered death and
Rose Immortal Usher in the new creation
so Sunday was mandatory for the early
church so when you answered it because
Christ is our rest it is in Christ that
we experience true Everlasting rest
which is what the Sabbath is right yeah
absolutely so we are observing the true
Sabbath because the Sabbath points to
Christ and this is what people don't get
everything in the Old Testament was
written to point to Jesus Christ
everything the
festivals the holy days the sacrifices
the temple creation everything and I've
done series on this so you'd have to go
back watch all the series but just to
show you from scripture where we're told
the sabbaths the new moon festivals all
of these the dietary restrictions were
designed in such a way to point to Jesus
Christ Our Lord and his work of ushering
in Everlasting rest so here let me just
give you the key text that we use let me
go now here right here Colossians
2 16 to 7 I know how they butcher this
but anyway right here here's the
principle therefore no one is to judge
you and food and drink meaning if you
have judaizers telling you you need to
keep Kash dietary restrictions of the
old test say no one can judge you don't
worry what they have to say about you or
in respect to a festival new moon or
Sabbath day you see don't worry about
those who want to condemn you because
you're not keeping their festivals or
Sabbath days why because all of these
are only a shadow excuse me of what is
to come but the substance belongs to
Christ so who is the
reality can you guys see my screen what
do you mean you can't see my screen who
is the
reality
Christ and he's the reality of what
the
Sabbath and not only Sabbath what
else there for no one sorry you can see
it but they can't see it I don't know
why guys I don't know why it's blank for
you guys hold on yeah my screen is blank
H okay guys I don't know why there's no
screen hold on hold on take it easy you
guys are panicking take it
e Dam that could is
I'm a little nervous if I if I fumble
and
okay no don't worry about it I don't
care what they say about
you let me see hold on why it's not
coming on let me see okay now okay it's
back now damn man when we come see right
it's all blank right why because that's
a reflection
of what's between your ears it's all
blank too so you're seeing an image of
what's between your ears nothing so even
what's is completely blank all right
anyway Jesus is the reality of all the
festivals he's the reality of what the
food and drink drinks represent he's a
reality of all of it meaning if you
believe the Bible if you believe the
Bible you're supposed to find how all of
these things point to Christ so hey y
the day of atonements how does that
point to Christ H Feast of Passover how
does that point to Christ Feast of
unleavened bread how does that point to
Christ you're supposed to ask that
question and then find how it all points
to
Christ you want me there yeah no
absolutely so that's the whole
point I've always wonder about sorry go
ahead Sam no no good brother well it's
kind of a separate issue so I can I'll
ask it later and I'll I'll let you
finish your point first you know I was
just saying so when they tell you why
don't you keep the Sabbath say I am
keeping the Sabbath because the Sabbath
points to Jesus my Lord ushering in
Everlasting rest which is mine when I
trust in him and I enter in communion
with him I'm now enjoying God's Sabbath
rest every day until the end of the age
but anyway go ahead what's your other
question